you're high your highness stars Danny
McBride James Franco Natalie Portman and
Zooey Deschanel amongst other people and
I got a free screening of it and I went
to and I wasn't quite sure what to
expect I really know much about Danny
McBride I really like James Franco I
really really like Natalie Portman and
Zooey Deschanel was good at 500 days of
summer so you know there's a lot of good
things going on here those people will
probably ask I have not seen pineapple
Express the director of that film
directed this film as well this film
about a man named Thaddeus played by
Danny McBride and his brother James
Franco is just the most revered Prince
of the land and everyone likes him and
everyone wants to be him so he's very
jealous he wants to go on his own quest
and eventually what happens is they
actually end up having to go on a quest
together to save James Franco's
bride-to-be from an evil wizard and this
is a comedy and it's a very very raunchy
comedy in fact I was definitely not
prepared for the raunchiness of this
space I'm not gonna give anything away
but there's just a lot of gross-out
humor in this movie and it got very very
tedious there was just too much there's
definitely a lot of money Python like
inspiration to this movie but this one
just doesn't have the wit that those
films had the problem with this movie is
it seems like it found a few things that
were funny and it just kept using them
throughout the entire film for the first
few times they did it it was funny when
they would throw in a modern slang or
modern word that was not normally used
back in the day it was funny though
first few times like huh that's funny
but then they kept doing it for the rest
of the movie and after a while there's
only so many times you can hear a
character say a modern-day word and it's
just it's not funny anymore
the other problem is yes unfortunately
all of the funniest parts are in the
trailer there's actually only one part
in this whole film where I
laughed out loud so to speak and that's
simply because it wasn't in the trailer
and there was it was pretty funny some
of the good things about this film Danny
McBride James Franco and Natalie Portman
they're all pretty good I don't really
know what Zooey Deschanel is doing in
this film I mean it just seemed like she
can I just sat there I was just like oh
no Oh like the action scenes were
actually pretty good I was pretty
surprised some of them were very well
done
a lot of good stunt work and some of the
action scenes the film is not boring at
all and it has a good pace but they just
went so far with the gross house stuff I
mean the point wasn't becoming a huge
distraction at time you know if you're
into that kind of humor I'm not really
that big on it but if you really like
kind of gross-out humor kind of stuff
then you might enjoy more than I did
some of the locations were good as well
like a lot of it looks really nice some
of the sets were done well the film had
a really nice production value that the
actors did a nice job there were some
funny parts it's just missing the wit
and the cleverness a lot of the comedy
is just very cheap I'm gonna give your
highness two and a half out of four
stars it's a no way a horrible movie
it's just missing a lot of the wit that
a commie like wish to have